[Musique]
bonjour à tous et merci de nous
rejoindre pour ce nouveau numéro d'
europe hebdo je suis ravi de vous
accueillir ici au parlement européen à
bruxelles c'est parti pour une demi
heure d'actualité européenne dans cette
édition nous irons en belgique qui
depuis 2016 applique une taxe
kilométrique pour les poids lourds
un système qui rapporte aux pays plus
que l'ancienne ville y est
deux mois après la catastrophe de
l'effondrement d'un pont à gênes en
italie
focus sur une taxe qui permet déjà
d'entretenir les infrastructures
routières en belgique
nous débattrons ensuite de
l'instauration de cette taxe poids
lourds au niveau européen avec nos trois
invités
mais d'abord nous partons en roumanie où
était organisée ce week-end un
référendum sur la question d'inscrire ou
non dans la constitution l'interdiction
du mariage homosexuel une consultation
particulièrement polémique à l'heure où
quatorze membres de l'union européenne
autorise des pionniers les pays bas en
2001 aux quatre derniers en 2017
l'allemagne l'autriche malte et la
finlande en roumanie en tout cas le
référendum a échoué faute de votants
c'est un revers pour le gouvernement
social démocrate qu'il avait appelée de
ses voeux
explication aurait dit à face
[Musique]
les roumains ont boudé le référendum
seuls 24% des électeurs se sont déplacés
aux urnes ce week end
insuffisant pour valider le résultat
alors qu'un seuil de participation de
30% étaient requis initié par les
sociaux-démocrates au pouvoir
ce scrutin vise à ancrer dans la
constitution l'interdiction du mariage
gay il répondait à la demande des ong
proche de la puissante église orthodoxe
réunis au sein d'une coalition pour la
famille même si sur le fond cette
consultation ne devait rien changer
comme dans la plupart des pays d'europe
de l'est le mariage homosexuel n'est en
effet pas autorisée en roumaine
une victoire du oui aurait cependant
signifié une prise de position affirmée
pour la défense de la famille
traditionnelle
la ligne prônée par le gouvernement
l'échec du scrutin marque donc une
défaite pour le parti au pouvoir
les opposants avaient appelé au boycott
ils ont été entendus
les roumains ont préféré rester chez eux
dénonçant un gaspillage d'argent mais
aussi une campagne aux accents
outrageants envers les homosexuels
et pour en discuter j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir sur ce plateau cristian dan
preda bonjour vous êtes roumain
eurodéputé du parti populaire européen
alors le gouvernement roumain avait
organisé ce référendum sur deux jours
samedi et dimanche c'était pour
maximiser les chances de participation
le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que ça
n'a pas fonctionné où il savait et puis
si vous regardez l'histoire électorale
roumaine depuis le 19e siècle jusqu'au
jour d'aujourd'hui c'est la
participation la plus modeste jamais vu
donc il ya vrai il y avait vraiment le
sentiment que les gens ne sont pas du
tout intéressés
en dépit du fait que non seulement le
parti au pouvoir le parti socialiste un
parti libéral mais aussi les partis
d'opposition avaient une initiative seul
un petit parti un nouveau parti avaient
dit non avait demandé aux électeurs de
rester à la maison et voilà c'est ce
petit parti qui a finalement gagné en
disant rester chez vous ça n'a pas de
sens c'est inutile dans le droit dans le
code civil on a déjà une définition du
mariage communion d'une femme et d'un
homme donc entendu cela dans la
constitution c'est vraiment inutile
alors les réactions ont été vives et
nombreuses à l' annonce des résultats
surtout à gauche je vous propose que
l'on s'arrête sur certaines déclarations
va commencer par celle du président du
groupe des socialistes et démocrates au
parlement européen l'eurodéputé udo
bullmann qui déclare nous sommes
fermement solidaire de la population en
roumanie peu importe qui il m
nous condamnons toute tentative de
discrimination envers les couples
homosexuels
de telles idées trompeuses ne devrait
faire partie d'aucune constitution en
europe il ya aussi ce tweet un de sylvie
guillaume également membre du groupe des
socialistes et démocrates qui déclare
pour une fois on se félicite d'un taux
faible de participation presque autant
de participants que deux promoteurs du
référendum réaction enfin d'une autre
députée française du groupe des
socialistes et démocrates christine
revault d'allonnes quand le peuple mais
une tarte aux populistes et toujours
jouissif je me réjouis de l'échec du
référendum contre le mariage contre le
mariage pour tous alors on le voit un de
vives réactions à gauche et ce qui est
très
étonnant c'est qu'avec ce référendum
c'est le gouvernement qui est social
démocrate qui est totalement à
contre-courant des gauches européennes
justement il ya cette rupture est donc
ici au parlement européen ne comprends
pas vraiment pourquoi les chefs
démocrates de roumains sont toujours
membres de ce groupe
de l'autre côté on voit certains
solidarité des autres partis sociaux
démocrates avec ce parti au pouvoir en
roumanie quand il s'agit de la
corruption on n'a pas vu les critiques
qu'ont adressé ailleurs du côté des
sociaux démocrates qui sont vraiment
très tolérant quand il s'agit de la
corruption en roumanie est très sévère
quand il s'agit de ce référendum qui
était quand je dis à farfelu inutile et
cetera donc je sais qu'il ya eu des voix
au sein du groupe socialiste au
parlement pour que les chefs démocrates
roumains soient éliminés du groupe à ce
que c'est vraiment des populistes des
gens qui sont très proches des milieux
conservateurs
il faut dire d'ailleurs que cette
initiative du référendum est venu
initialement des églises protestantes
qui ont su réuni d'une alliance de
toutes les églises zidane bien sûr
l'église la présomption d'églises
orthodoxes mais aussi les catholiques
seul une église
l'évangélique l'église évangélique était
contre l'idée de ce référendum sinon il
ya eu un consensus très fort et on voit
cette montée de l'an fluence du les
ligier sur les affaires publiques
alors il faut préciser aussi un que ce
gouvernement est en perte de vitesse
après ses nombreuses attaques visant
l'indépendance de la justice on se
souvient de la révocation de la chef du
parquet anti corruption en mai dernier
ce sont des sujets qui fâchent jusque
dans cet hémicycle et la roumanie
pourrait être le prochain pays visés par
la procédure de l'article 7
après la pologne et la hongrie
finalement cristian dan preda
ce référendum est ce que ce n'était pas
un moyen de détourner l'attention de ses
sujets qui fâchent parce que
malheureusement pour le pays j'allais
dire
en particulier pour le parti
social-démocrate le chi le chef de cette
organisation était condamné deux fois
pour corruption il reste toujours le
chef de la chambre des députés
et il a été obligé parce que la loi lui
interdit de faire partie d'un
gouvernement de dirigeants gouvernement
il a trouvé des plumes miss étaient
faibles qui chante vraiment manipuler
donc on est dans une logique de
démocratie non transparentes où les
décisions sont prises à l'extérieur du
gouvernement comme cat schiste en
pologne qui co contrôle des
gouvernements livide ragueneau de
contrôle et un gouvernement qu'on a eue
après les élections de 2007 c'est donc
ça crée un sentiment dedans qu'on force
démocratique si vous me permettez
l'expression parce que les gens ne se
sent pas de plaisanter de tous les côtés
en plus il ya cette volonté de couper
court la lutte anti corruption
une femme qui a fait énormément de
choses pour la lutte anti-corruption
madame kfw chez était effectivement
démise de ses fonctions après des
manoeuvres politiques tu es libre et
donc il ya eu des protestations dans la
rue justement parce que les citoyens ne
veulent plus entendre parler de ce mode
de faire de la politique il y a tout de
même une majorité qui est très faible
socialiste et libéral a big à reims
comme je le disais tout à l'heure
malheureusement les groupes socialiste
et libéral du parlement européen ne se
sépare pas de cette politique comme nous
le ppe on l'a fait par exemple un
rapport à victor et donc c'est un peu
curieux de voir ce paysage qui est un
peu confus quand il s'agit d'un rapport
des différentes forces politiques aux
familles alors vous en avait parlé en le
président du parti socialiste liviu
dragnea qui est déjà condamné pour
trafic d'influencé qui est poursuivi
pour corruption finalement cette
abstention massive 1 lors de ce
référendum est ce que ce n'est pas le
signe d'un ras le bol de la population
face à la corruption de cette classe
politique oui et puis dans tout pays
démocratique j'imagine que dépenser 40
millions d'euros pour un référendum
complètement inutile ça
nivea incertaine des missions enfin
quelqu'un qui assume sa non il n'est pas
question de ça sonné le jour d'après de
retour à la grande question comment
limiter la dépendance la justice parce
que malheureusement ces saints la
volonté du gouvernement a annoncé à des
petits progrès qui ont été faits depuis
dix ans et pour finir un j'aimerais
revenir sur ce drame qui a eu lieu en
bulgarie où une jeune journaliste
d'investigation a été sauvagement tué
samedi dernier le motif de ce meurtre
reste encore mystérieux mais l'on sait
que cette journaliste enquêtait sur des
cas de corruption dans son pays
voyez ce tweet de joseph daul un
président du parti populaire européen
qui déclare je suis consterné par
l'horrible meurtre de la journaliste
bulgare victoria marinova je presse les
autorités bulgares d'agir immédiatement
afin de mener une investigation
approfondie et indépendante pour
conduire les auteurs de ce crime devant
la justice
nous devons défendre la liberté de la
presse et soutenir nos démocratie et
l'état de droit finalement cristian dan
preda c'est le troisième meurtre de
journaliste dans un pays de l'union
européenne ces douze derniers mois
votre réaction je suis très triste
d'autant plus que cette journaliste
avant d'être tué elle a fait une
entrevue avec un journaliste
d'investigation roumain aux tirs au but
dont qui a été à son tour arrêté en
bulgarie à deux semaines parce qu'il
enquêtait sur la corruption dans ce cas
que et les autorités bulgares et les
autorités roumaines ont le devoir de
protéger les journalistes
d'investigation
ces gens là sont pleins de courage c'est
des gens qui veulent faire de la lumière
sur des affaires de corruption
qu'il s'agisse d'aider les gens qui sont
liés au parti ou non ces jeunes à l'isd
investigations doivent être vraiment
protégé par les autorités parce que
sinon on assiste à des à des drames à
des tragédies comme ça vous l'avez
mentionné c'est le troisième pays après
malte et slovaquie et on déplore bien
sûr toute atteinte à la liberté de la
presse est d'autant plus à la halle à
vis des journalistes
merci cristian dan preda d'avoir été
très vite et aujourd'hui cap désormais
sur la belgique qui depuis plus de deux
ans a remplacé l'eurovignette par une
taxe sur les poids lourds chaque camions
de plus de 3,5 tonnes roulant sur le
territoire belge doit payer un montant
fixé au kilomètre on se souvient de la
levée de boucliers en provoquer en
france par le projet d'écotaxe qui avait
finalement été abandonné par le
gouvernement en 2014 en belgique en tout
cas sa mise en place a déjà rapporté 686
millions d'euros en 2017 c'est plus
qu'avec l'ancien vignettes et le système
permet déjà d'investir dans les
infrastructures
explications dans ce reportage signé
fabien becker
[Musique]
sur ce viaduc les tractopelles sont à
l'oeuvre
d'immenses dalle de béton déposé au
centimètre près par une grue seront
bientôt recouverte d'un bitume tout neuf
cette autoroute relie mons et tournai le
long de la frontière avec la france
chaque dalle a été construite en usine
elles sont toutes différentes les unes
des autres et alors ça sert de coffrage
parce que par la suite on ferraille est
en beta 1 au dessus
le chantier a démarré l'année dernière
et doit être terminé avant l'arrivée de
l'hiver
coût des travaux 10 millions et demi
d'euros des chantiers de ce genre se
multiplient partout en belgique une
trentaine pour la seule wallonie grâce à
une nouvelle manne financière
un prélèvement kilométrique sur les
poids lourds alors ceci c'est le boîtier
ici nous avons ce qui a marqué alexis
combien on va payer ça change par
rapport à la wallonie et la flandre lors
pour l'instant comme on est en france
c'est gratuit
[Musique]
depuis 2016 ce boîtier est obligatoire
pour tous les véhicules de plus de 3
tonnes 5 belges ou étrangers qui roulent
en belgique
corentin fille rennes ce travail pour un
transporteur français parti de tourcoing
il va enlever des marchandises au port
d'anvers ce jeu là c'est encore gratuit
et ça devrait pas tarder à changer
alors maintenant l'aï marqué zéro euro
c'est le temps que ça capte avec le
satellite
bon alors 13 centimes du kilowatt
donc au plus je vais faire des
kilomètres au plus en plus on va payer
le tarif est calculé en fonction du
tonnage de la motorisation et du nombre
de kilomètres parcourus la fiscalité
routière est une compétence des régions
qui applique chacune leurs tarifs mais
wallonie flandre et bruxelles ont
toutefois créé une entité commune avec
une petite dizaine de salariés
viapass gère le dispositif pour le
compte des régions
le système fonctionne et génère 586
millions d'euros par an qui est quelque
part un bon moyen financier pour les
régions pour les investissements en
mobilité en infrastructure tout
automatique mêmes contrôles automatiques
donc on a 400 millions d'euros par jour
et gare aux contrevenants une
quarantaine de portiques comme celui ci
équipé de caméras vérifie
d'immatriculation et la masse des
véhicules en plus des équipes mobiles de
contrôle sillonne les routes comme ces
agents de la région de bruxelles à bord
de leur camionnette ils vérifient grâce
à un ordinateur si ce camion portugais
est en règle
ici par exemple donc là pour le moment
on ne sait encore rien dire parce que le
système caméra étant derrière il faut
d'abord qu'on le dépasse
une fois qu'on va le voir dépasser le
système va le référencer ici à l'écran
voilà ici on voit qu'il est en ordre
toutes les données sont au vert
on confirme encore en voyant qu'il est
bien payé donc pas de soucis pour ce
camion là en cas d'infraction l'amendé
grimpe jusqu'à 1000 euros
ceci c'est le terminal de paiement pour
les paiements donc environ contact et
qui permet donc aux personnes qui ont
été attrapés malheureusement si on peut
dire ça comme ça à effectuer donc le
paiement des amendes parce qu'ils ne
repartent pas sans avoir effectué
effectivement le paiement des amendes
qui sont à percevoir
en 2017 plus de la moitié des recettes
de la redevance provenaient de camions
étrangers
si contrairement à la france la belgique
n'a pas connu de levée de boucliers
contre la mesure
c'est aussi en raison de sa situation
géographique la situation de la wallonie
ou de la belgique globalement est
peut-être un peu particulière par
rapport la france parce qu'on est un
pays avec beaucoup plus de transit que
la france en particulier et donc le fait
de faire payer à juste niveau
les transporteurs étrangers ç'a permis
de mieux faire passer le principe de
cette redevance et d'autre part ben on a
dû mettre en place toute une série de
concertations avec le secteur notamment
pour l'est les aider à passer à des à
des camions de meilleur de meilleur
impact environnemental car c'est l'autre
objectif de la redevance
incité par la fiscalité les
transporteurs à renouveler leur flotte
vers des moteurs plus propres
donc moins taxés un impact
environnemental non négligeable
l'année dernière les poids lourds
européens ont cumulé plus de 6 milliards
de kilomètres sur les routes belges
[Musique]
et pour en discuter j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir sur ce plateau christine
revault d'allonnes bonjour bonjour vous
êtes française membre du groupe des
socialistes et démocrates et vous êtes
l'auteur d'un rapport sur l'euro
redevance absolument
face à vous aujourd'hui mathias menge
bonjour bonjour vous êtes président de
la délégation de l'organisation mondiale
du transport routier ici à bruxelles
et pour compléter ce plateau j'ai le
plaisir de recevoir lucas tripoteau
bonjour bonjour vous êtes journaliste à
l'agencé europe
ici à bruxelles et vous êtes spécialiste
du dossier transport
alors pour commencer une première
réaction christine revault d'allonnes au
reportage que l'on vient de voir avec
elle cette taxe kilométrique en belgique
qui paraît assez vertueuse alors qu on
se souvient de la levée de boucliers qui
avait provoqué le débat sur l'écotaxe en
france alors ça m'a beaucoup inspiré
quand j'ai travaillé sur le rapport qui
met fin aux vignettes pour passer au
système de redevances à l'échelle
européenne qui est l'enjeu du rapport
dont vous avez parlé qui est pour
l'instant sur la table du conseil de
démontrer qu'en belgique cela se passe
cela est accepté
pourquoi parce que tous les camions sont
concernés pas uniquement des camions
étrangers comme on peut l'entendre dans
des informations françaises et surtout
parce que c'est un système qui est juste
qui s'appuie sur la distance parcourue
la question de des vignettes qui
existait jusqu'à l'or est un système
complètement dépassé puisqu'il s'agirait
de payer quel que soit le nombre de
kilomètres parcourus
on le voit le nombre de kilomètres rien
qu'en belgique dans ce reportage
effectué par des camions est énorme et
il y a aucune raison qu'il n'y ait pas
une prise en compte du principe
d'utilisateur-payeur on utilise la route
donc on paye en fonction des kilomètres
parcourus
donc c'est un excellent exemple et aussi
je trouve que l'utilisation du satellite
pour parvenir à ce péage et quelque
chose vers lequel on devrait s'orienter
y compris en france et alors justement
vous en parliez le gouvernement français
qui évoquait il ya quelques semaines une
taxe qui s'appliquerait uniquement aux
camions étrangers est ce que c'est
possible
une vignette une vignette c'est possible
non effectivement ce n'est pas possible
parce que l'union européenne est
toujours été fondée sur des principes de
non discrimination
et la réglementation actuelle
effectivement prohibe toute
discrimination directe ou indirecte et
simon
ne prend pas forcément le transport de
marchandises stricto sensu
l'allemagne avait envisagé il ya
quelques années de mettre un système de
vignatti aurait dû s'appliquer de fait
aux citoyens étrangers
la commission avait pointé du doigt ce
projet est finalement après des
négociations il ya eu un accord entre la
commission et d'allemagne donc a priori
pas possible et vous et mathias réduire
votre réaction à ce qu'a annoncé le
gouvernement français
ou je ne sais pas maintenant dire au
gouvernement français c'est ce qu'il
faut faire mais de semble que le secteur
comme industries concernées autour de
fait qu' il faut pas imposer des taxes
chaque secteur et chaque trame aux
transports doit couvrir ses frais mais
si on prend les frais du transport
routier pour développer le transport
ferroviaire ou le marketing à notre vie
ça fonctionne pas il faut vraiment avoir
une allocation obligatoire des frais
dans le secteur transport il nous faut
l'infrastructure comme on a vu il nous
faut les parkings sécurisés
il faut investir dans les carburants
propres et tout ça il faut tenir en
compte
il faut avoir il faut avoir une marche
pour le faire le march moyens de notre
secteur 7 2%
donc si on impose plus des charges dans
notre secteur on se pose les questions
s'ils ne sont capables de l'avertir de
nos futurs alors justement à votre
rapport christine revault d'allonnes est
assez ambitieux il va plus loin que s'il
avait préconisé la commission européenne
il propose notamment d'introduire une
redevance liées aux normes écologiques
pour les poids lourds mais aussi pour
les voitures est ce que vous conseille
pas que ça va faire grincer des dents
certains états membres
peut-être que ça va faire grincer
certains états membres mais il n'empêche
que ce rapport a été adopté au parlement
européen et que je crois réellement au
fait qu'il faut que cette redevance
s'applique à tous les véhicules du petit
véhicule au grand véhicule et y compris
aux motos comme nous le connaissons déjà
en france avec les autoroutes ou les
péages concerne tous les véhicules
il est extrêmement important de prendre
cela en compte est ce que nous proposons
c'est de sur la partie concernant les
émissions de pollution
donc effectivement un camion diesel euro
3 pollue beaucoup plus qu'un camion
diesel euro 6 et polluent beaucoup plus
qu'un véhicule essence ou et en
et ou encore mieux un véhicule
électrique donc on prend en compte le
niveau d'émission des véhicules pour que
la redevance pour ceux qu'on appelle les
coûts liés à la pollution soit adaptée
au niveau de pollution et pour qu'il y
ait à la fois ce système
d'utilisateur-payeur vous passez à des
redevances partout en europe à un
système aussi où on prend en compte le
principe de pollueur-payeur
on est dans une situation où on a un
enjeu économique est aussi un enjeu
écologique et les deux sont liés et on
peut très bien lier les deux dès lors
que ce principe s'applique à tous et là
c'est un principe de justice et d'équité
qui je pense permettra d'être acceptée
par l'ensemble est pas uniquement par
les poids lourds même si c'est vrai
qu'en termes d'émissions de pollution
ils le feront beaucoup plus donc c'est
là que se jouera la différence avec un
véhicule léger et contrairement à
monsieur je pense que les recettes
perçues par ces redevances doivent aller
à la fois sur la rénovation des routes
mais aussi sur l'ensemble des transports
et surtout les transports les moins
polluants possibles
justement mathias médias us ce dernier
rapport du giec qui est alarmiste sur le
réchauffement climatique on disait quel
serait selon vous les alternatives à une
déco redevance pour diminuer les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre du
fret routier
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec madame
selon selon de fait que soit tout le
monde ou personne
ça c'est un principe énormément importe
important mais il faut faire attention
au niveau de l'internalisation des coûts
externes parce que le co2 on paie déjà
assez via le prix de carburant et les
plis et les prix augmentent
beaucoup ces joueurs là mais en même
temps nous soutient qu' il faut soutenir
les alternatives les nouveaux
technologie christine revault d'allonnes
une réponse à monsieur mais dieu alors
on est en train de discuter sur un autre
rapport qui est le niveau d'émissions de
co2 pour les poids lourds
c'est la première fois que la commission
européenne s'intéresse à mettre en
passionnant pour les poids lourds et je
sais parce que je travaille beaucoup et
je discute beaucoup avec le secteur des
transporteurs routiers qu'il ya des
vraies réflexions et en recherche et
développement pour faire en sorte que
nous ayons des camions de moins en moins
polluant et donc c'est un objectif qui
est tout à fait envisageable
donc là dessus il n'y a absolument
aucune difficulté mais la question liée
aux coûts du carburant c'est il faut
plutôt se poser la question de est-ce
qu'on va continuer à utiliser du
carburant
est ce que c'est ça ce qui va nous
permettre de faire avancer nos voitures
et nos poids lourd demain puisque on a
sept cette question-là réglé par rapport
à cette utilisation de l'essence et
surtout du diesel
donc c'est plutôt le sujet là plutôt que
de dire on veut plus être taxé par
rapport à cette à ce type de là on en a
besoin pour les faire avancer
mais demain c'est pas ça la solution
donc juste être à court terme c'est par
rapport à l'augmentation de la taxe sur
les carburants ne résout rien et c'est
vraiment au niveau de la recherche et
développement et du changement de type
de motorisation combat à bruce alors je
réussis une question de calendrier
puisque évidemment mai prochain il ya
les élections européennes est ce qu'il
ya une chance d'avancer sur cette
directive avant cette échéance on a
priori il a très peu de chance donc pour
pour expliquer cela il faut revenir un
petit peu sur le fonctionnement de la
machine européenne
donc la commission a présenté cette
proposition dans le cas d'un ensemble de
propositions en mai 2017
et pour que les propositions
législatives puissent effectivement
entré en vigueur il faut un accord entre
eux donc les députés européens et les
états représentés par le conseil donc
chacun se prend une première proposition
et ensuite ils négocient pour avoir un
accord donc effectivement au parlement
européen nous avons cet accord
maintenant
par contre au niveau ministériel les les
ministres planchent depuis des mois sur
d'autres questions de transport qui sont
aussi extrêmement sensible sur les
aspects sociaux et de marché du
transport il n'est pas prévu pour le
moment de discuter de ce texte d'ici à
la fin de l'année et la roumanie qui va
piloter les travaux ministériel à de
janvier à juin n'a pas encore communiqué
ses intentions donc on ne sait pas si
elle travaillera mais à priori c'était
quand même très compliqué d'avoir un des
grands l'impression de calendrier un
christine revault d'allonnes elle est
importante
oui elle est importante mais ce que je
regrette vraiment c'est que le conseil
toujours sur les singes sujets
environnementaux a beaucoup de mal à
prendre la mesure de des objectifs et du
défi que nous devons auxquelles nous
devons répondre et sur cette question de
la mise en place d'une redevance ça
concerne les étapes ça concerne surtout
les régions qui partout en europe sont
celles qui ont en charge le réseau
routier et ces régions ont été très
impliqués dans cette dans cette
proposition de révision de cette
directive et était tout à fait
favorables aux propositions que je
soulevais d'ailleurs y en avait beaucoup
qui était convergentes et il y en a une
qui a pas été mentionnée mais auquel je
tiens beaucoup
c'est le fait de considérer que ce ne
seront pas que les états membres mais
aussi des autorités locales
donc les régions qui pourront définir
quelles sont les routes qui sont
concernés par ces redevances et dans les
recettes qui seront perçues elles
pourront aller vers ces régions
on a vu le reportage en belgique où ce
sont bien les régions de wallonie et de
flandre qui font ces travaux donc c'est
extrêmement important et il faudrait que
le conseil entendent à la fois le
parlement européen mais aussi les
acteurs élus locaux qui sont ceux qui
travaillent sur ces questions là et
qu'ils agissent et qui investit
et mathias malzieu un mot pour la fin
quel est votre sentiment vis-à-vis de
l'avenir du fret m'intéressait beaucoup
notre secteur pour l'instant c'est pas
dire si nous sommes en faveur ou contre
ce qui est important et puis il faut
avoir une approche preuve notre secteur
sur la route représentent 15 % de la
circulation
si un débat et la proposition d'un cuir
la circulation comme un coup externe
il faut absolument contestées il ya 300
millions de voitures sur les routes en
europe et chaque jour jusqu'à 7 millions
les camions et si on propose également
inclus et les bus c'est pas obligatoire
mais il se pose des questions et
problèmes parce qu'une buse représente
aurait place trois voitures
si vous voulez mettre la marchandise
d'une camion de 40 tonnes dont des
voitures au niveau de volume on parle de
plus de 200 voitures
donc il faut vraiment avoir un approche
coran je crois on peut parler la
pollution les émissions et toussaint on
veut mais aurait tout le mois de mai
aurait mais il faut le faire
correctement et j'insiste et ça c'est
mon dernier mot il faut pas passer les
frais d'investissements
d'infrastructures pour un système de
péage aux opérateurs ça c'est sur ce
qu'est notre secteur énormément beaucoup
parce que j'ai dit la marche c'est déjà
très peu il faut contrôler les coûts
merci beaucoup c'est ainsi que se
termine notre débat aujourd'hui merci à
tous les trois d'y avoir participé
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis et
vous pouvez retrouver cette émission en
replay sur nos différents sites lcpan
public sénat et rtbf.be je vous souhaite
une belle semaine à tous et à très
bientôt
[Musique]